remember this day my name is Walter Camp
and you will regret you ever heard my
name it's a unique traffic stop to say
the least when Florida sheriff's
deputies pull over 67-year-old Walter
Camp they get more than they bargained
for I'll tell you right now on camera I
will kill that mother from the threats
of murder to beastiality you're sucking
mother and and I I go back there and
your dog in the ass right now flashing
his to onlooking drivers I'll take my
pants off no no I don't want you to take
your pants off I I don't have no weapons
and claiming to be a sniper with Mafia
connections from 1500 yard see how fast
you can be from 1500 yards when a bullet
right in your
head you can't stop it John it's Mafia
this arrest is nothing if not memorable
you have any kids what you have any kids
I don't really think that's your
business I'm gonna them in the
ass if I don't do it I'm gonna have
somebody else them in the
ass keep going there you go I want you
on the camera to know this it all
started on November 2 as a drunk driving
investigation that's when Monroe County
Florida sheriff's deputies pulled over
Walter Camp for suspicion of drinking
and driving how's it
going how are
you I'm definely right with the
sheriff's office I know you are I'm
sorry I know who you are you know who I
am yes how do you know who I am doesn't
matter okay well I'm stopping you for
passing in a no passing was there any
reason for that uh the guy cut me off
that guy cut you off yes okay when was
that right before I did that right
before you passed him yes body camera
video captures the traffic stop as
Camp's strange Story begins
where are you heading to now Key West uh
where you coming
from
Washington is this your car it's a
rental it's a rental car do you have the
rental agreement yes can I see it if you
must almost immediately Camp denies he's
been drinking how much have you had a
drink none none none not that big Bud
Light right there that it's been sitting
there since the last night okay how much
have you had to drink today none
okay this my rental agement right here
okay perfect why don't you to step out
of the car come back to my car we'll
talk back in my car step out of the car
first see that okay I got it let's step
out of the car we'll go back and talk to
my car okay but when he gets out of the
vehicle Camp makes a shocking move
pulling down his pants right in front of
the Deputy you don't have any weapons on
here or anything no mind just lifting
your shirt up not like that that's
perfect come on back here here I'll take
my pants off no no I don't want you to
take your pants off I don't have no
weapons the deputy breezes past Camp's
quick flashing and moves on instead to
the smell of alcohol coming from his
breath here's the deal what's the deal I
can smell a heavy odor of alcohol coming
from you when you when when you talk so
uh o the odor of the alcoholic beverage
not alcohol itself um from last night
okay your eyes are bloodshot glass last
night okay your eyes are blood shot and
glassy yes sir you're slow in your words
no I'm not you are 100 okay that's
fantastic fantastic so here's what I'm
going to ask okay uh would you be
willing to participate in some voluntary
field sobriety exercises I would not
okay you don't want to uh why not why
not
why why would why why what why would I
participate uh well I'm requesting you
to I'm not going to request that no okay
I don't need you to request it I'm
asking you would you be willing to
participate in voluntary fils exercise
to dispel my belief you're operating
that motor vehicle that's right while
you're under the influence of okay well
I believe you are well there you go so
my training through my training
experience well that's your training and
experience okay I've been doing this a
long time okay so I've been driving for
a long time 6 seven years when he says
no to all the field sobriety tests Camp
is placed under arrest well that's
fantastic I'm going to go ahead I'm
fantas I'm going to ask you again yes
sir would you be willing to participate
in voluntary field exercis okay turn
around for me yes sir put your hands
behind your back yes
sir I might be a place arrest yeah yeah
don't step be say yes you're under
arrest for Dy 100% you are Camp then
begins speaking nonsense telling the
deputy to call someone he refers to as
the commander to help him get off no I
am not okay I refute this you you refuse
to be arrested and I refuseed this I
know the commander who's the commander
the Key West Commander you call him
right now and tell him Frost you tell
him you pull Frosty over who is that
just call him who who do you want to
call just call him who who am I calling
the commander of the Key West commander
of Key West yes 40
years who is the commander of qest just
call him okay I don't understand who
you're asking me to call I'm asking you
to call him I don't know who that is
well call him anyway call somebody I
don't know who it is he's your office
he's your your uh he is your
supervisor's call him he's my supervisor
yes call him right now you know his name
he will know my name who just call me uh
you're not giving me a name to call he
you know how many people that I work for
there's only one Commander there's not
there's not even a commander at all
that's not even a there's only one the
police chief a police chief yes do you
see who I work
for I don't work for Key West Bubba okay
Bubba I don't work for Key West Police
gu what what's up call him anyway next
the sheriff's deputy asked Camp about
the marijuana inside his vehicle other
than that giant bag of marijuana is
there anything illegal there is nothing
illegal in that car a giant bag of
marijuana is illegal there's nothing
illegal in that car okay do you have a
Florida medical marijuana c i do did you
buy that marijuana at a dispensary
what marijuana are you talking about the
marijuana that you open your console and
slam her shut because it's sitting right
there there is no marijuana in my
car despite the deputy finding some
marijuana inside the car Camp still
denies he has any instead he tells
another deputy on the scene he's looking
for some I need some marijuana
actually got I don't have any man right
now that sucks man well I can use some
I'll it from
Unfortunately they don't uh they don't
Supply marijuana in the jail so I'm not
going to jail where are you going I'm
going to be released here in a few
minutes you are yes oh
okay you don't so you don't have weed in
the car no if I had some I would smoke
it oh what was it in like tree trimmings
I didn't see whatever he saw he said he
Tre trim I don't know he say what you
talking about he said he saw what looked
like marijuana so it's not marijuana he
can see whatever he wants he's a
Visionary I'm sure as one Deputy
searches Camp's rental car he continues
speaking with the other Deputy
eventually yelling out profanities you
you guys been mean since you pull me
over I haven't done anything then why am
I in cuffs then I didn't put you in
handcuffs I didn't well why am I in
cuffs then because Deputy Rody put you
in handcuffs well it he's anle there
okay and he's going to give a reprimand
from the from the chief of police
okay we don't have a as soon as you can
release me he's going to get reprimanded
and get I'm going to call the commander
and he's going to be fued up well we
don't have a commander and we don't have
a chief of police guess what we have a
sheriff you know the
sheriff I'm not talking to you okay do I
have to do you have to talk to me yeah
no it's your First Amendment right to
not talk to me thank you one of the
parts of it was the right to remain
silent that's right I choose that but
you keep talking to me again after you
say that Walter well cuz he's a okay
well tell him that I will okay but he's
shoot me he won't shoot you I won't I
won't let him shoot you while I'll stand
in
front well no you got to stand right
here for
now you can
say there you go man
he said he said I could do that your
partner said I could do
that all right now now let's be nice
okay yeah you got to get get it out now
now we're going to be nice right Walter
be let's be nice okay but Camp does not
act nice instead things really heat up
and he begins threatening the deputy who
pulled him over when I get out the
commander is going to your pension your
woman up and your pant house up and you
up Moody
rudyy no put my phone back was thank you
very much you understand that you're you
understand put the phone
back he trying to help you Walter he's a
you're
nice I'm black I can keep with these Cs
on Camp's threats go from minimal to
outrageous threat thre in to rape the
deputy's wife and family later and his
dog okay and his and his women and his
kids probably I might even his
kids weird when it's all done it's weird
but what the he's weird so
I'm as weird as he is John his
kids how are you going to do that well
we'll see how that goes
[Laughter]
okay hey you got any you got any females
in your
family does he have females I'm not sure
well his kid too
okay of
course or if I don't do it I'll have
somebody else in the when he's at high
school whever he's at College
me okay yeah this is not over John what
if it's like a 8-year-old well I don't
care oh well I didn't get cuffed by an
8-year-old okay can
get I'm not sure man I think so I think
so it's kind of a weird thing to think
about though to be honest not really
well around here it is well he just me
so I'm going to his
kids probably shouldn't do that and then
before howling camp threatens to
sodomize the depuy's canine you're a
sucking mother and and I I go back there
and your dog in the ass right now
because she would let
me it's a boy well
to CU he would love me CU I'm a wolf I'm
a
wolf I don't think I do not think he
would like
that he would like it I don't think he
would I think he would but the threat
just keep on coming I'm your kids and
your children and your wife and your
everything else all right cool and you
just earned a felony another
one good job get it on baby good
job get it on baby oh no when you talk
about get get it on baby you have any
kids what you have any kids I don't
really think that's your business I'm
going to them in the
ass if I don't do it I'm going to have
somebody else them in the ass
keep going there you go I want you on
the camera to know
this you know
what what I just
said is that it that's it that's all you
wanted me to know yeah I'm going to take
his Pion his kids I'm have his kids and
this is high school I'll find out where
his kids go to school and
[Applause]
have cost like $1,000 hey everybody this
is a Morgan and Morgan legal alert
evidence shows that Google has allegedly
violated the privacy of millions of
Americans via incognito mode your
personal information and data may have
been unfairly collected and then used
for profit as America's largest injury
Law Firm Morgan and Morgan has recovered
over $20 billion in compensation for
clients and they may be able to help you
fight for justice if you've used
incognito mode in Google's Chrome
internet browser you can find out if you
have a claim in only a few clicks by
visiting www. forthepeople.com
lcg gooogle it only takes a few minutes
to sign up and find out if you have a
claim eventually Camp tries to backtrack
saying the deputies may have just
misunderstood him maybe you
misinterpreted I don't think there's any
way to misinterpret that you're going to
have a black man his kids or that you're
going to that's probably true but I
don't know I don't know how other way I
don't know when will happen you even
told me you're going to his kids in the
that's a pretty direct statement well I
don't know that's your that's your
interpretation yeah but what other way
could you interpret that well a judge
will interpret it
differently okay well I I disagree with
you on that Walter you can just me Camp
says he's been Cooperative but soon
changes his tune have I done everything
you asked me to do well the main thing I
asked you to do is stand there and you
have done that Walter I'll give you that
thank you very much thank you sir and I
want to tell everyone that I cooperated
totally with the the Monroe sheriff's
department and I'm telling you right now
judge that this is an
improper um
citation and I request release tomorrow
with no charges thank you
okay my will handle the
rest
they're $1,000 an hour I don't know no
lawyers down here that are that
[Music]
expensive that's some like corporate
business account lawyer yeah
very well this isn't really a corporate
business infraction who do you know what
maybe you don't know nothing I know most
of the attorneys down here you nothing
do down here you don't know nothing
I know a few things you don't know
nothing
okay but I like G I appreciate that
Walter and I'm cooperating okay I will
not do anything against in Monroe
Sheriff's Department thank you
okay only kid gets that you said I could
do that you said that I can say wherever
I want to get well you call him a but
you can't threaten him or threaten his
family well
whatever we'll we'll settle that in
court okay yeah calling someone aad or
flicking us off telling us to go
ourselves that's all fine I don't care
about that people say that to me all the
time fantastic I just smile and wave
you're a good guy yeah but someone says
they're going to do something to our
family I kind of you know it's a
different story you can't say that yes
what cuz that's a threat yes what uhhuh
I won't do it okay I'll have somebody
else do it
well there you go again Walter I didn't
I what John well that's the same thing
man you can't pay some you can't say
you're I say whatever I want free
country done okay well I'll see you in
court that that'll be an argument for
the judge by the way okay you going to
take it to trial yes okay I look forward
to it I'm going to sub you that you I
cooperated every ounce of the way okay
never resist your realiz never said
anything opposing to you John only
the okay when searching Camp Shar
deputies confirmed he purchased the Bud
Light inside the vehicle the same day as
the traffic
stopped but I do have
aiper this is not he bought the six is
not over sir what's not over this what
your life is over but not this 11 a.m.
11 a.m. and the all that was in the car
empti perfect after a deputy reads Camp
his Miranda rights Camp claims he's a
sniper and what he refers to as a fourth
degree black belt well guess what if he
anything comes out of that car I'll kill
him too okay well that's I'll tell you
right now on camera I will kill that
mother Walter you got to stay back man
there you go man I don't like it when
people get close to me well there I'm
just trying to tell you okay I like my
personal space you know I it's a good
thing because I can kick you in the face
right now okay well you probably
shouldn't do that well I I'm a fourth
degree black belt a fourth degree black
belt I can put my foot above your head
wow that's pretty agile man don't piss
me off I'm saying I couldn't do that
well I can't I'm almost 30 years old 67
years old I can barely sit down without
my back I can kick your ass and him too
and drive off but I will not do that
okay well I appreciate that Walter I
well I'm giving you the benefit of Doubt
okay well thank
you and I can kill that dog too
okay you think your weapons scare me I'm
a
sniper okay I can shoot you 2,000 yard
right between your eyes I thought it was
1500 yard I'm qualified 1500 yard you
can do 2,000 2,000 y That's pretty far
yeah he's then loaded into the back of a
squad car you got some long hair man
yeah got some it's down to the my
knees all right you don't know who
you're fucking with okay you have no
idea okay just take a seat for me of
course I'll be out tomorrow morning okay
and that guy will be dead in in 6 months
sounds good Walter there you go don't
put your hat right here okay well you
can you can you can put me down that
he'll be dead in 6 months and on the
ride away from the scene the threats
just continue he's
dead you can mark that your
calendar I he kill his dog
too and his wife and his
kids there you go tell him to have a
good day John same then
enjoy your next 6 months cuz he's going
to be dead my god father is a
mafia made man and that mother the guy
that just arrested me is dead in 6
months and his kids and that dog that
barked I'm going to make sure they kill
that mother dog
it's aute dog F that dog it's a nice dog
well it's going to die so
enjoy you enjoy yourself
John you don't know who you just
arrested you're not you that guy who is
that
guy officer
what deputy what Rody Rody yeah Rody he
will no longer exist of this
planet it could be now it could be next
month it could be 3 months from now he's
dead
okay come on film I know it he's dead
Rody is dead you might as well get
another deputy cuz he's
but once the ride is over Camp doesn't
slow down you're actually dead not you
don't exist somewhere ready okay so go
home and kiss your wife and Say
Goodbye okay thank
you I can't refuse that one man you're
you're dead I can't help it I'm sorry
you gone too far I'm giving him a chance
John to say goodbye that's decent of me
isn't it yeah it's a nice thing to do
well in the field we don't let people
say
goodbye but in reality I'm giving my
chance
John that's all I can do from 2,000
yards try to find me
[Laughter]
brother try to find me I can be off the
island before you even find out he's not
here Camp's story soon flipflops from
him being a sniper to him hiring someone
to kill the deputy I won't be pulling
the trigger by the way going be someone
else well we got peoples you know you
heard about
Peoples Peoples Peoples no I don't know
what that is Walter that means we got
peoples that will do me a
favor and I'll do them a favor later on
so I can be in Australia when it
happens you know what I mean it's an
tell anything
John if you don't have peoples you don't
have nothing
John but Camp switches his story once
again then saying he'll be the one to
kill the deputy see I know who you
are so I know you're
ared so I will take you down and kill
you before you can pull your fire before
you can pull your firearm you be dead
you understand me yes there you go yes
before you can before you can pull your
firearm you would be
dead pretty fast there you go I'm pretty
fast at it well from, 15500 yards see
how fast you can be from, 1500 yards
when a bullet right in your
head with nearly 300 threats to murder
rape and attack multiple people camp now
faces several charges including
resisting an officer intimidation and
threatening with death or serious bodily
harm his bond was set at more than
$772,000 reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie